ce qui me captive dans la science
fiction c'est le goût de l'étrange
l'étrange se situe un peu plus loin
l'inconnu l'inconnue c'est ce que nous
ne savons pas l'étrange c'est ce que
nous ne soupçonnons pas l'avenir ne nous
est pas juste un inconnu
il nous est soupçonné ce n'est pas le
manque de savoir qui nous le rend
obscures dans un monde déterministe le
savoir suffirait à la prédiction mais
notre monde est tissée dans des
entrelacs de chaos et de probabilités et
même des prédictions à un an s'avère
aléatoire
pour compliquer le tout nous ne sommes
pas étrangers à notre futur notre
société et gourmande en prospective de
tout genre et là patatras la prédiction
prédictions historique est un système
chaotique a bouclé outre rétroactive un
peu comme la bourse
si nous pouvons anticiper un avenir
probable nous pouvons modifier nos
actions pour réformer cet avenir et du
coup l'avenir anticipé n'existera jamais
nous voilà bien avancés
et si nous avions un gros puis de
gravité qui nous fasse glisser dans la
trame de l'espace temps et nous ramène à
2050 que verrions nous serions nous dans
l'inconnu serions nous dans l'étrange
serions nous capables de comprendre ce
que nous voyons spontanément je crois
que nous tenons là un bon critère est ce
que nous partageons avec les gens de
2050 le même univers mental le même
univers fictionnel comprendre l'avenir
ce serait comprendre les récits des
hommes de l'avenir
mais quelles peuvent être ses récits et
surtout en quoi les récits sont ils le
meilleur vaisseau pour nous conduire
jusqu'à demain les hommes sont ce qu'ils
disent
cela peut paraître un peu contre
intuitif pourtant ça fait soixante dix
mille ans que ça dure il y à 70 milles
en homo sapiens fait une invention
considérable il n'invente pas le langage
les animaux ont leur langage les autres
hominidés avaient leur
âge homo sapiens invente la fiction le
récit avec la fiction homo sapiens gagne
quelque chose également de considérables
une suprématie sans partage comment par
une coopération de masse avant le récit
il ya le commérage le commérage est un
système extrêmement efficace pour créer
et entretenir une cohésion de groupe
d'une centaine d'individus
il permet de savoir qui est l'ennemi de
qui qui couche avec qui qui tient ses
promesses et qui triche mais au delà de
150 individus ça marche plus on perd la
connaissance d'un team
au delà de 150 individus il faut le
récit est avec le récit homo sapiens
devient capable de s'organiser en bande
de 200 500 800 individus et tous les
autres hommes se couche
l'homme de l'île de flores l'homme du
lac rodolphe l'homme de denisova en
sibérie néandertal le récit permet la
coopération avec des inconnus sans
besoin de connaissance intime
il permet de concevoir de décrire ce qui
n'existe pas ou ce qui n'existe pas
encore
non seulement les avenirs probable mais
d avenir insoupçonnée des futurs
divergent disruptif avec le récit homo
sapiens a mis un volant sur le moteur de
l'évolution et avec certains récits il a
mis dans ce moteur de l'hydrogène le
carburant des fusées alors les récits ce
ne serait pas que l'imaginaire nous
plaisons à distinguer ce qui relève de
ce qui est imaginaire le réel c'est
simple c'est le monde sensible ce que
nous pouvons toucher son voir ce sont
les rivières les montagnes des couchers
de soleil et puisque nous construisons
les trains
les panneaux publicitaires mais qu'un
aliens débarquent dans l'une de nos
villes et croyez moi ils ne
comprendraient pas grand chose pour
comprendre ce que nous voyons il lui
faudrait d'abord écouter ce que nous
disons il faudrait partager nos récits
mettons nous un instant dans la peau de
cet alien plutôt dans sa tête
est-ce que nous continuerions de croire
qu'il existe réellement quelque chose
comme nestlé quelque chose comme les
droits de l'homme les républiques des
cimenteries des dollars la réalité c'est
que toutes nos constructions
nos organisations nos coopérations sont
des intrication complexe de récit nestlé
est une fiction
noël est une fiction un de mes
professeurs de droit avait coutume de
dire j'ai rencontré des agents publics
des comptables publics des
fonctionnaires de toutes sortes mais je
n'ai jamais rencontré l'état je ne sais
pas ce qu'est l'état
eh bien l'état est une fiction la france
est une fiction un cycle sont nos
territoires
nos frontières mais également nos
maisons nos métiers et jusqu'à nos
propres noms n'habitons pas dans des
villes ou des pays nous habitons dans
nos récits que nous cessions y croire et
tout s'écroule
et pourquoi est ce que nous continuons à
y croire et bien parce que nous avons
sacrément intérêt car qu'est ce qui fait
un bon récit un bon récit c'est une
création mentale qui nous donne un
avantage respectifs c'est une fiction
avec laquelle l'homme qu'au évolué pour
le meilleur et pour le pire
le meilleur c'est la reproduction et
l'expansion du récit et de l'homme qui
le porte
le pire c'est l'oubli c'est facile c'est
comme pour les jeunes un bon récit se
transmet par ce qu'il nous donne un
avantage évolutif
d'ailleurs un biologiste célèbre richard
dawkins a donné un nom à ce phénomène
les mêmes avec un axe
grave même gène génétique mémétique la
même éthique étudie la co évolution de
l'homme et de leurs récits maintenant
réfléchissons cette co évolution si elle
vient du monde du vivant
eh bien on va y retrouver des
caractéristiques par exemple comme dans
le monde vivant la différence est
fertile l'équivalent du sexe dans le
monde des récits c'est la dialectique la
dissonance cognitive comme pour les
jeunes les récits se transmettent ils se
reproduisent
il mute certains sont récessif d'autres
dominant avec les récits nous sommes
donc capables de co évolué en nous
organisant et en coopérant dans des
mondes en dénombre de plus en plus
grands nous sommes de plus en plus
nombreux à coopérer ensemble c'est la
raison pour laquelle les bons récits et
plus efficace tant à converger vers
l'unité
en dépit des résistantes parfois très
violentes de récits partiel ou locaux
les bons récits convergent vers de
grands récits universel nous y voilà
pour aller à 2050
nous devons trouver de grands récits
universelle qui nous permette de co et
veiller jusque là alors quelles peuvent
être ses grands récits il y en a
sûrement un très grand nombre
je vous en propose trois le premier de
ces récits c'est grand récit universel
c'est presque l'idéal type de la fiction
c'est celle qui a gagné le coeur de tous
les hommes tous les hommes en veulent
parce que tous les amis croient tous les
amis croient parce que tous les amoureux
c'est la monnaie les sorciers des temps
modernes ce sont les banquiers avec 0,8
qui peuvent créer 10 les moquées savent
très bien que la monnaie est une fiction
c'est la raison pour laquelle il
mise pas sur la monnaie sur l'argent
mais sur la croyance que nous avons dans
le futur de cet argent et qui fait que
l'argent est bien de l'argent pour miser
leur faut des cotations côté c'est
quantifier la quantité de croyance que
nous avons dans cette fiction d'avenir
et si la monnaie qui est le récit le
plus fluide et le plus universel montrer
le chemin et si les banquiers avaient un
coup d' avance pour mesurer nos actions
aujourd'hui l'unité temporel et le
d'ordinaire le mois ou l'année bilan
mensuel trimestriel annuel pour les
entreprises on vote tous les quatre ou
cinq ans pour apprécier la crédibilité
d'une action politique
et si la l'évaluation de nos actions
collectives se faisait en continu en
permanence il nous faudrait alors tous
côtés et dans tous les sens nous
pourrions côté noté nos voisins nos
politiques nos fournisseurs nos clients
des passants nous pourrions donner dans
un restaurant non seulement une cote à
la cuisine aux serveurs mais également
aux à nos voisins de table
ce ne serait plus le supérieur
hiérarchique qui apprécierait un an de
travail met au jour le jour
toutes les personnes tous les
professionnels avec lesquels nous
collaborons en continu
toutes les actions collectives invisible
aujourd'hui apparaître est un exemple de
l'émergence de ce récit de ce grand
récit hubert vous savez les concurrents
des taxis c'est la principale valeur
ajoutée d'hubert les conducteurs notent
leurs clients et les clients notent
leurs conducteurs
alors bienvenue en 2050
à ce temps toutes nos actions
collectives seront cotés en permanence
par les uns et par les autres
cette co évaluation des actions nous
permettra de nous apprécier en
permanence et pourra même être une
source de revenus pour le meilleur et
pour le pire
l'autre grand récit universel que je
vais vous proposer
c'est celui c'est un récit politique et
c'est le retour d'un grand géant oublier
fernand braudel a donné un nom aux
économies florissantes du passé les
cités états italienne de la renaissance
la france la grande bretagne et ses
colonies l'économie monde ait jamais ce
nom l'économie monde a été aussi
pertinent tous les hommes aujourd'hui
vivent dans l'économie monde la même
économie monde et que faut-il pour
gouverner un tel monstre il faudrait une
fiction qui soit capable de maintenir la
paix car dans une économie monde
planétaire la paix est plus rentable que
la guerre et ces pillages il faudrait
une fiction politique qui soit inclusive
et polyculturelle afin que toutes les
cultures l'acceptent
en dépit de leurs différences
cette fiction politique existe elle a
même gouverner la plupart des hommes
depuis 2500 ans
cette fiction c'est de l' empire et
voilà le retour d'un grand jeu
oublier l' empire maintient la paix dans
son territoire il est inclusif et
polyculturelle le récit l'avenir de 2050
ce pourrait être un récit mutants de la
pax romana et du commun code
d'hammourabi des signes d'émergence de
ce récit les grands accords commerciaux
internationaux ne sommes nous pas en
train de coopérer internationalement
pour taxer leurs échanges et le
changement du climat
les grands empires du passé se sont
créés par la force des armes
c'est peut-être là qu'il y aura un
changement avec l'avenir seule la
fiction bâtir à la vampire qui vient le
troisième grand récit universel c'est la
possibilité d'une rupture et cette
rupture pourrait provenir d'une
révolution la révolution d'un récit très
particulier qu'est la science et c'est
la révolution biologique pour les
biologistes notre cerveau nos émotions
sont des systèmes biochimiques qui sont
issus de millions d'années d'évolution
mais nous avons un problème nos gènes
sont restés à l'époque l'un longue
époque des chasseurs cueilleurs nomades
l'époque où les graisses et les sucres
et terreur époque où nous marchions
pouvions marcher de longues heures dans
une même journée et nos gènes ont fait
de nous d'incomparables marcheurs mais
notre monde moderne nous conduit à
rester assis des heures durant devant
des écrans d'ordinateur et à manger des
barres chocolatées
nos jeunes ne sont plus adaptés à nos
fictions moderne
mais un récit est une pratique
l'ingénierie génétique nous donne la
possibilité aujourd'hui de modifier non
plus nos mêmes ce que nous faisons
depuis soixante-dix mille ans mais
directement le code source de notre
patrimoine informatif nos gènes alors
quels avantages comparatifs pourrions
nous en tirer nous pourrions réaliser un
grant aggiornamento génétique faire
correspondre nos gènes anneaux fiction
moderne ou inventées réinventer un
génome pour qu'ils correspondent à des
fictions futur quatre cinquièmes de la
surface planétaire c'est de l'eau
pourquoi ne pas devenir une créature
aquatique
nous pourrions changer transformer la
formule du bonheur cette formule en
biochimie nous la connaissons sérotonine
ocytocine taupe amin pourquoi ne pas
faire correspondre la libération de ces
hormones a par exemple une expérience de
coopération peuvent pacifique et en quoi
cela serait-il moins choquant que
l'association actuelle avec par exemple
la pêche d'un poisson nous pourrions
également vous donner plus de temps à ça
c'est un récit en cours en 2050 grand
nombre de chercheurs considèrent qu'ils
existeront les premiers hommes à mortel
qui ne m'auront plupart les ismes on a
donné un nouveau nom à ce récit le
transhumanisme mais en réalité c'est le
plus vieux récits du monde
la quête d'immortalité de gilgamesh mais
ce que l'ingénierie génétique a de plus
intéressant à nous apporter
c'est une véritable rupture un futur
totalement divergents revenons une
dernière fois en arrière il ya 2000 ans
disparaît l'homme de l'île de florès il
ya 30 millions des andes et al quarante
mille ans l'homme de dennis aux femmes
et si l'extraordinaire n'était pas de
recréer le mammouth le dinosaure mais
néandertal imaginez un peu le tableau
nous pourrions co évoluer dans ce monde
à côté de nos frères et nos soeurs ce
humains non sapiens pour la première
fois depuis douze mille ans homo sapiens
ne serait plus le seul représentant de
l'humanité nous pourrions avoir faire un
bon génétique par la simple reproduction
naturelle avec nous pourrions partager
avec nos fictions et voir quelles sont
leurs propres conceptions leur propre
façon de réinventer nos même en 2050
l'humanité atteindra un plafond
démographique de 10 milliards
d'individus pour la première fois ce ne
sera plus le nombre qui peut être le
qu'il sera lé l'avantagé évolutif
ce ne sera plus la quantité d'hommes et
la qualité d'homme c'est un récit très
étrange
personnellement c'est celui que je
préfère c'est le récit de l'altérité
humaine il dit l'humanité sera plurielle
nous ne seront plus jamais les seuls sur
cette planète et nous ne seront plus
jamais les mêmes
je vous remercie